[Music]
it's a huge pleasure to welcome you back
to hey on why I say back because I see
many of you have been here many times
before and I hope you have and will be
coming again and we're starting this
evening with a debate that I suspect
will be provocative and stimulating in
equal measure it's titled darkness
Authority and dreams and to discuss the
core question at the heart of it
do we need authority what kind of
authority do we need our and we're
getting overseas transmission there as
well do we need Authority what kind of
authority do we need and how might we
rethink Authority for the future we have
three very distinguished speakers
joining us we have on my left although I
think not on anyone elses left so to
speak Professor Deirdre McCloskey
professor emeritus at the University of
Illinois in Chicago an immensely
distinguished economic historian on my
right a professor melilla
of Columbia University author amongst
many other books of the recent very
successful vol the once and future
liberal and joining us from I think
Cambridge Massachusetts professor now
I'm Chomsky who won almost says needs no
introduction but of course immensely
distinguished public intellectual
professor of linguistics at MIT and the
author of a very large number of very
distinguished books in times that at
least some people consider to be dark
troubled turbulent do we need Authority
and I go to start if I may with
Professor Deirdre McCloskey well we we
need some Authority I think is he is the
obvious answer to this but but a much
smaller amount than we now have the
problem about Authority is that it's
basically the art of pushing people
around of men pushing women around the
cops pushing poor people around
the United States pushing everyone
around and and I I think we need to draw
back from this idea that we need laws
and authority to run everything I have a
cousin who works for the CIA she she
said to me and she's very reasonable
person and she said well you know a
modern economy needs a lot of
supervision a lot of authority a lot of
people making regulate any trust clause
and blah blah blah and I said no it
doesn't I I think that like language to
speak of our colleague here what
language is a is a spontaneous order
it's not there's not some central
committee that's deciding what
conjugation should be in English and the
same is true of the economy and the same
is true of a lot of our life much more
than people think and they think oh we
gotta have a boss here and regulations
and all gosh and then we have to pass
laws all the time now really I say let's
stop passing laws let's have a year in
which we don't pass any laws in
Parliament or Congress and see what
happens I think we'd be better off there
are too damn many laws too much
authority did we thank you very much
indeed for that for a cogent statement
there I think the way the US Congress is
going not passing the laws might soon be
the norm in US v John Stuart Mill type
19th century liberal we think that it's
a good thing that Congress can't do
anything yes and I would like to think
deirdre that John Stuart Mill in
particular would have worn that sparkly
top I could see it very very much on on
him there
but lemma we've heard from dead in
Wroclaw ski that we're passing too many
damn laws too much Authority get off our
backs
is this a viewpoint that you can agree
with no I think we suffer from an
authority deficit and different kinds of
authority the original authority problem
if you go back to Plato and Aristotle
its authority over the self yes how do
you become a subject capable of reaching
your own goals and setting goals and
reaching them well that only comes when
you have you know the rational part of
you or the moral part of you has
authority over other parts of you now
and the only way to establish that
because it doesn't come naturally to us
is through education and the only way to
help people become authoritative over
themselves is to give them authoritative
education there is no spontaneous order
of becoming a self a self conceived in
society through authority
we're also suffering an authority
deficit when it comes to social morays
you know if 50 years ago today or now
back at back in 1968 people were very
happy to question all sorts of
authoritative mores and taboos having to
do with the treatment of women now what
we're trying to do is reconstitute those
taboos and those mores and those norms
because we got rid of many of them and
for many for understandable reasons
hypocrisy and all the rest but how do
you do that we have to do that in some
authoritative way young boys need to
learn how to treat young girls and women
when they get older that requires that
certain Authority yeah finally at the
political level Donald Trump is right
now destroying as many democratic norms
she possibly can know what our norms
norms are not things written down there
are things that are authoritative
because they become taken for granted
yeah the thing about it taboo is you
don't know you have a taboo until you
use lose it it's in that moment that
it's gone that you realize that up until
then it never would have occurred to you
to call for your political opponent to
be jailed yes and then once that happens
the question in all these realms I'm
talking about is how do we put the genie
back in the bottle and so I think we're
- I think Americans a particular are a
paranoid about authority they have been
since Tocqueville wrote and one of the
problems with that is we put so many
constraints on Authority while at the
same time asking more and more from
government so that government cannot
actually provide the things that were
asking them to do so we have to choose
either we ask for fewer things or we
give more leeway and discretion to those
in public office in order to reach the
ends that we want to so in all those
sorts of ways I think we actually need
to think through and reacquire an
appreciation of authority but within
that Montella there is presumably a
distinction to use highly sophisticated
terms between good Authority and battle
authority you're not talking about
simply obeying norms or ideas because
they're there already because they're
inherent
well part of the way norms work is that
and the reason they're authoritative is
because you're not questioning them or
at least when you're educated in them
you're not questioning them you begin by
taking them as authoritative and then
hopefully later on either you question
I'm going to reject them or you
appreciate the reason you know behind
them but but we we should do I don't
think we should be asking the government
to do so much I don't think we should be
turning to the government all let's hold
that thought there if I move debates
already breaking out on stage but we
have another voice to hear professor
no-trumps you've just heard from Mark
Miller here in hey the case for more or
authority in the right sort of authority
would you agree with that case or would
you want to argue against it argue it's
dipped in a qualified fashion there is a
general simple principle that authority
namely that any form of authority the
domination hierarchy are not itself
justified but they face a burden crew
and if they can't meet it which i think
is commonly the case they be dismantled
here here
paper the more free and just social
order well there's many different facets
this consideration who has to pay
attention do we need Authority in dark
times first important recognize that yes
indeed because in a hand in the any
spoons they minutes to midnight poses in
the terminal disaster was open one
objection I think this breathing be
Wesen it Soviet man exploded the
fighting bombs who reasons a
environmental and the environmental
catastrophe and ask what authority deal
with these issues
the only thing better wait wait question
the proper question is whether the
authority helps for harms in dealing and
I think it we we we see it quite
characteristic one the environmental
catastrophe acting accelerated with the
authorities acting accelerate who raised
construction technique
no counterparty evil practice by
literally taking your boy deliberately
that's better
it's called a marital deduction and it's
often possibly reckless facts of the
other issues and it's a learn to achieve
voluntary subordination to the Thark
there was a meeting of all 40 is that
whatever please Prince has the force of
law since the people have yielded up to
him their power and authority voluntary
and contractual mission rules
philosophical act we reject that burden
in fact plant reality we don't think the
European Union of part of its biggest
problems is that Authority has been
ceded went on elected birthday and the
consequences were quite great religion
electronically populism better
understood as the rejection of
illegitimate power and authority with
the United State Tennessee fencing
research from academic science joining
that a single variable campaign funded
it is remarkable precise predictions of
electability programs pursue other
research shows that a large majority the
population is literally disenfranchised
and that their representatives they know
and attention to their opinions living
its name the voices of the wealthy and
the powerful so more authority and they
just pick alas how long they
country foundation for economic worthy
they very closely resemble two
philosophical accident
contractual Commission rule the ruling
authority and in the early days of the
Industrial Revolution such arrangements
were literally and then wage slavery the
differing from travel Superion ligand
the length of the tenure of the laborers
the finest may obtain but the principle
remain and I think there in greetings
question whether an authority or
legitimate professor Chomsky may I take
that point which you've articulated very
clearly and throw it to our fellow
panelists here to get some discussion on
that we would like to bring it back in
and just at just a moment I think Noam
Chomsky said several things there that
we should pick up in terms of thinking
about this question of how and whether
centralized Authority is essential for a
society to work effectively and actually
the last part of what Professor Chomsky
said more I'd like to throw to you
you've written a great deal about
identity and without caricaturing you've
argued that identity politics in some
ways is becoming very corrosive of
democratic society let me take a
specific example that I think relates to
one aspect of what Noam Chomsky's just
said supposing you are one of the many
african-americans who feel that the
police one obvious sense of a source of
authority in society do not represent
your interest do not have your interests
at heart are not protecting you in your
community in an inner city in the United
States is that a form of authority which
they should be respecting and taking
account of or do they have a legitimate
legitimate case to say this is something
that is widely recognized as
authoritative but we don't feel it
should be for us oh sure it's very
understandable but one has to understand
that and if I can back up to answer the
question
that I I reread recently Lenin's attack
on Rosa Luxemburg which is called
infantile leftism and I realized that he
was totally right and Rosa Luxemburg was
totally wrong it's a life you've
endorsed Leonard yes
you know I'm becoming more Leninist by
the day I think but the point is that in
the end you need a party you need
Authority you have to work within a
system of something and there is a kind
of infantile leftism that talks about
Authority in the way Kafka talked about
the castle there's a thority there's the
wall and we have social movements where
we come up and we're ramming the door
and every once in a while authority
tosses things down to us right that is
not the way democracies work and we
cannot exaggerate the problems of
legitimacy in our democracies that know
there are doors into the earth into the
into the castle there are conversations
about how about things we might do
certain people have more voice than
others that's absolutely right but it is
not a wall and one consequence of
infantile leftism is that in rejecting
Authority if it throws itself into the
hands of the so called people yeah and
one populist Tribune yeah yeah that
pretends to speak for the peace and
there's a long list of that beginning
from the Soviet Union down to Hugo
Chavez and a certain kind of infantile
leftist that falls in love with these
truly authoritarian figures because
they're against Authority well I agree
with that
in part because indeed if you're going
to do politics by majority vote which
which which ends up with Chavez or urban
this this this fellow in in Hungary as
an example or god help us Donald Trump
that's where you're appealing would not
you but one is appealing to a
a majority rule we vote and then the
minority is crushed you jail your
political opponents and so forth but
there's a third way which is not
infantile it's an optimism about
self-organizing humans free humans and
indeed as an economist of course I'm
very enthusiastic about this notion that
a market society doesn't need massive
walls massive authorities castles
telling them what to do I think you're
right that if you take the political
view of naive democracy you're going to
get naive results are great journalists
in the United States and the early 20th
century
HL Mencken said democracy is the theory
that the common people know what they
want and deserve to get it good and hard
[Laughter]
objected to man's conception that the
role that the public should subject
itself to the party itself to the
central committee it should sell for the
maximal leader it would construct the
labor army of answering would return to
the modern society we have to ask
ourselves does the majority in the
United States
this is majority thinketh our answer is
No as I went it up briefly literature
there is overwhelming evidence that
elections were initially bought
assistant Shan Shan who can predict the
outcome of an election simply by looking
campaign funding and that's only one of
the many factors but which concentrated
wealth and workers power to determine
the nature of legislation with lobbying
nao devices and in fact the large
majority of the population are indeed
underrepresented their own
representatives disregard their opinions
probably and pay attention to the same
centers of power so it's simply not true
that from you you don't the formerly
that's possible but in fact it isn't and
the same is true of labor contract as a
classical liberal I who agree with John
Stewart and bill that the proper form of
Association in an economic system is for
working people control their own
enterprises not be subordinated to
masters the which is a kind of temporary
slavery as they called it temporary if
you sum this way of getting out then oh
yes I think that's the question we're
seriously the actual role of authority
the way it functions in creating dark
times in imposing repression populism
shouldn't mean and it probably does mean
of taking seriously Thomas Jefferson's
distinction between aristocrats
want to appropriate to themselves hope
our linen was example versus the
Democrats regard the common people it's
their opportunities for what's now
called
Liberty democracy to be the safest
possible common interest could I put
that point professor Chomsky back to our
other panelists here I mean Martin Lilla
it seems to me that infantile leftist
versus future liberal is possibly the
worst superhero movie ever but if we
wanted to get past today would you
accept Professor Chomsky's proposal that
the basis the actual basis of what he
would call so-called liberal democracy
is so corroded so corrupt that actually
the pillars of authority that you're
putting forward don't really have
validity in the first place no because
what's being compared is our present
reality and the disaster of our campaign
finance system which I agree with
entirely with some fantasy of a
plebiscite like democracy that is not
the democracy we have in fact we have
constitutional democracy and it was
constructed in a certain way so that
authority was would be diffuse in
different sorts of institutions they
would lean against each other in
disagree with each other in other ways
it's an indirect democracy and that
allows consultation and frankly gives
room for elites to be in a room and to
reflect on these things and our great
powers that we get to put people into
office is that eventually we can get rid
of them and that's the test I think but
I think without putting words in Noam
Chomsky's mouth you would say that you
can substitute a Democrat for a
Republican but essentially they all come
from the same sort of background with
the same sort of assumptions and the
same sorts of prepares there it's not
really a choice but there's there's an
underlying problem here with with both
see
infantile but very distinguishable of
distinguished colleague in the end the
and the fascist I don't actually mean
that but that we're all we're both of
them are assuming that our lives should
be entirely political and that politics
should dominate the economy the society
that that's where all the action is and
I I look left and right it's simply an
argument over how massive state power
will be used on the left encouragement
of class warfare on the right
encouragement of in the imperial
expansion a curse on both their houses
let's move to a less governed Society
I'm gonna go back to professor little
and then to professor Chomsky it was the
CIA Desert it was the area's cousin my
cousin I'm hoping we will get professor
Chomsky on the line because that was
actually a really rather well well we do
that too I mean III agree with Dina
McCloskey more than she might think yeah
and if you are the first part of the art
of authority is that to the extent that
you can have spontaneous order you
should have there you go right will join
and so but to the extent that you have
government that
axé it must have authority within the
realm that it does there were so the
American movie mr. Smith goes to
Washington has a lot to answer for
yeah there's this idea this kind of
Frank Capra view of politics in America
that you can find some cornpone guy you
know who's this pure individual and
he'll go to Washington and I'll see how
corrupt everyone is and you know the
people will flood in and and everything
will change all that's President Trump
right right yeah American movies are
like that what are they about some
corporate structure right and there's
one computer programmer there
understands everything and the
journalists won't listen to MIT
eventually they overcome them and that
makes Americans suspicious of Authority
I would like more limited government but
worth orotate of government in the
things that government does well I agree
with you there but look in in 1913 the
share of all levels of government
expenditure state federal local in the
United States was about seven and a half
percent of national income of all the
stuff produced in the country seven and
a half percent now it's 32 percent okay
but dipped across he let me come in on
that one of the reasons it rose so fast
was two little things one called the New
Deal and on the back of the Great
Depression and when the Second World War
yes are you suggesting the United States
either should not have dealt with the
Great Moderation or fought the Second
World War
well I have great criticisms of Franklin
Roosevelt's economic policy I guess art
into arguments with my mother is 95 on
these matters and machines in FDR but
the authority of the American system by
the end of the nineteen
have been heavily corroded by the fact
that capitalism at that time seemed to
have failed and put up you yeah but
haven't failed and hasn't failed look oh
here we go we're we're vastly we're
vastly better off in in in in nineteen
forty one just take one date the average
income in the United States was what it
is now in Brazil and I love Brazil it's
a wonderful place but it's poor and I
hope it will stop being poor but the way
it's going to stop being poor is the
spontaneous order of the market and and
I and I want to make again this point
that language is a spontaneous order and
an argument is a spontaneous order and
the and the and the common law is a
spontaneous order and they work
reasonably well they're not perfect and
and we don't need to be bossed around
all the time
professor Chomsky would you say the
spontaneous order of the market will get
us through well actually I've lost the
last sorry we got most of it actually
there but which we're just at thanks for
coming back into the discussion with
1941 yeah we're much richer we have all
sorts of evidence that we that for most
of the population that stops at around
1980 the principles were instituted by
now real wages birth majority however
it's true that we're much Richard late
40s we have all sorts of things we
didn't have then but for example what
we're now using the computers and the
internet where do they come from they
come from the market yeah it's not yeah
they came from the dynamic State
the economy namely clever decades for
decades the creative and risky work was
done either in under taxpayer subsidy
either in institutions like my own MIT
other research institutions under under
taxpayer subsidy to but that
institutions like IBM which were
subsidized and finally when IBM was able
to create a computer that was fast and
usable button select so it was bought by
the government institution Los Alamos
well establish that procurement is a
major way in which the taxpayer meaning
the state subsidizes private enterprise
and of a large extent what we call a
market is a system of public subsidy in
private marketing in the profit and we
ought to face the reality I agree with
you're gonna cost me we shouldn't take
orders and that includes personally the
orders that are taken by a worker who
rents himself who was young the idea
that that private wealth and portrait
power don't have an overwhelming effect
on choice of on legislation that's a
form of subordination to power that we
should not accept what I agreed with
gossipy that we should not doesn't
prosecute which is not they push the
political and the economic system
they're ugly interwoven but we should
face the reality of each of them and
question whether the authority that
exercise is in fact legitimate so you
had possible liberal principles well
that question of legitimate Authority I
think will lead us very neatly to the
next part of our discussion we I think
have had plenty of discussion but we're
not going to get agreement rightly so I
think on the question or whether we have
too much authority or too little in
various societies but I think we need to
bring particular human beings into this
more because the question of leaders and
leadership has also become a ver
every live one in the last couple of
years whether in the Western world with
the election of President Trump the
election of President macro in France a
rather different sort of leader from
Trump perhaps but certainly someone very
strong personality all the criticism of
some other leaders perhaps the leaders
in Western Europe including for some
throughout prime minister may as not
having enough authority enough
leadership then of course the emergence
of Arian in Turkey Xi Jinping in China a
whole variety of different sorts of
leaders and I suppose the question comes
if we turn from authority to
authoritarianism which is related but
different sorts of question in what
Lilla you obviously as other speakers
are a based in the United States you've
seen the phenomenon emerging there but
more broadly globally do you think that
we're entering a world where
authoritarianism is becoming too
attractive a way for leaders to operate
oh absolutely and and and what's
especially disturbing about it is that
these right-wing authoritarians are
learning from each other so you know if
my authority well that was more in the
past but now when or bond does something
it might be mimicked on the French right
and and so on and you know but but but
authoritarianism
I don't even sure it's the right word
I'm not sure what it has to do with
Authority I mean it has to do with
nationalism it has to do with racism and
has to do with anti-semitism it has to
do with militarism it has to do with all
sorts of things I don't know what it
makes it authoritarianism I think
probably idea would be in this case that
in in those cases that the authority is
embedded in the government indeed is in
this case the leaders sense of his or
her own sort of the terrorists
characterization of authority in that
sense I the leader of China I the leader
of Turkey I have a leader of the United
States perhaps these know the right to
do it while there's not a word for it
which is simply tyranny
and and I'm agin it I think that the
tyranny of the women of whites over
blacks over rich people over poor people
these are the things that I think should
be made not should be made how can I say
this smaller that is the the range of
authority that men had over over women
was once extremely large there's a
marvelous statement of this by someone
had said in the 18th century Kings had
power and women had none now it's the
other way around
and that's okay with me but he really is
the problem yeah okay but if we're
talking about certain leaders of
countries which have in a shrunk their
democracies that's one thing yeah would
you say that legitimately elected
Democratic leaders in the main you know
is angular Merkel a tyrant in Germany
that's a good no I don't think she look
like a she's a she's a German house bro
well she's more than that to be fair she
kept her you know a dissident background
came through a very very male-dominated
the question I mean is what is it that
makes angular Merkel not a tyrant and
presumably also who are you suggesting
is because because she listens to people
yeah this is the big problem and be be
afraid because Donald Trump doesn't
listen to anyone he thinks he knows
everything he's a complete fool and he's
very dangerous precisely for that reason
she listens to her opponents to her when
she did this terrible mistake of
a million people from Syria and she she
she reacted she's she's at least many of
Donald Trump's voters would say that he
listened to them and decided not to
letting a million people the United
States he did and that's that's the
trouble to to that doesn't make him a
tyrant that makes him so somebody
listens to a different set of people it
makes a lot tyrant when he does the
things that mark was pointing I know
what defines erupted every I think I
think I understand your question better
now someone like Aaron wants a good
example right where who someone who's
elected on the basis of a kind of
charisma and then proceeds then to
destroy the democratic institutions
within apart from the power of his
presidency if that's what you mean by
authoritarian is yeah that is a problem
so let me turn to professor Chomsky I
mean you have been very critical in the
first part of the discussion about the
nature of what you say is so-called
liberal democracy do you think that
tyranny and democracy can be clear
differentiated in terms of leaders who
who would you choose today as a genuine
Democrat and who would you say is
perhaps the elected tyrant misleading so
if we look at the European Union makes
the basic decision yeah it's not the
nationally the basic decisions are made
by the IMF unelected Commission and the
central bank and the reason one of the
reasons why we're seeing in Europe the
spread of populism in opposition to the
establishment establishment who
the centrist hundred leftover parties
that have plenty of opposition rage
anger fear part of the reason is that
the decision making has in fact been
further removed it was always quite
remote further removed from people
themselves and the decisions that are
being made at the high level beyond
popular control basically respond to the
northern banks but not to the population
the level of austerity that's headed by
our economic effects on large parts of
population that it is anger rage people
when we turn in here is Trump listening
to his constituents yeah oh yes one
major thing so achievements are for what
economist Joseph Stiglitz properly calls
the donor tax bill 1917 bill which forms
the general population arms Trump's
constituency benefit is actual atrocity
which is concentrated wealth and power
we've been observing in the United
States last year it's a sensible system
in which the figure in the White House
focuses attention on himself but
immediate attention on the from as
having showing up the pulse of history
often forgotten and while he's doing
that of the more savage main tip the
Republican Party Ryan
all the rest for ramming through
legislation which is extremely harmful
to their pretending addressing their
voters and everyone else contracting the
world in general so we cannot forget ye
the Doomsday Clock that's four minutes
to midnight that's an overwhelming fact
for passing everything else we're
discussing and it's largely because the
needs of actions that are being taken
under the Congress and others it's a
good game but it's very well but it's
extremely dangerous
yeah Bennet leading the rage anger
irrationality and some funds support for
Paris Matic figures so professor
professor jobs let me put that to the
other panelists of a mediator McCloskey
would you say that in a sense we
shouldn't be distracted by the idea of
charismatic leadership figures it's sort
of some type of people concentrate on to
the distraction to the real issues we
shouldn't be distracted and we wouldn't
be distracted if the leaders weren't so
important in it look let's take that
that seven and a half percent national
income in 1913 spent whereas now it's
over thirty-two percent in France it's
54 percent the government spends fifty
four percent of everything that's that's
produced in France
Henry Kissinger who I don't entirely
admire is a war criminal
but still he said correctly France is
the only successful communist country
and there's a lot to do that if if look
in in 1930 you have me to Massachusetts
but that there were appalling urban
politics in places like Boston where I
grew up or Chicago where I now live
extremely corrupt extremely interested
in this in the sense that professor
Chomsky is speaking of and yet it didn't
matter very much
it didn't affect most people in the
United States because the government was
confined it was small
it didn't matter now we have this
gigantic government and we're arguing
about how this gigantic power is to be
used and I wish I wish we would focus
more on trying to bring the gigantic
power under control so where would you
come in on this do leaders matter in the
end or not well they do but it's
possible to be mesmerized them and I
think misunderstand how certain kinds of
democracies work let me give you an
example had Hillary Clinton become
president she won the popular vote had
she become president and had she not won
Congress very little of her agenda would
have been passed and a lot of it would
have been blocked at the state and local
government for example a few weeks ago
the state of Iowa passed a law saying
that abortion would now be illegal from
the moment the heartbeat of the fetus
could be heard which is about six weeks
which is normally before most women know
they're pregnant now there's a
constitutional right to abortion in
America but the way the federalists
federal system works you have to go and
you have to win elections in all these
states and the huge problem for the
Democratic Party because it's become a
cultural elite party at the top because
of identity politics where it's focused
it's not able to develop a large message
or put its concerns about minorities in
a larger vision they're incapable of
going to a place like Iowa
and convincing Iowans if you want to
defend women it's not enough to elect
Hillary Clinton or knit a hat you've got
to go to Iowa win elections in an
overwhelmingly white state of people who
are very religious and that is the
challenge for the Democratic Party it's
not looking for a charismatic figure
it's working through the party from the
ground but it's worth pointing out just
on that mark as you just said at the
beginning of her own comment there if
you're looking at in terms of getting
people to vote for you more people voted
for Hillary Clinton than voted for
Donald Trump the Electoral College meant
that in fact she didn't get to win but
it didn't mean that people wouldn't vote
for Hillary Clinton or the devil or yes
oh no no but not at the state level in a
federal system we live in a
geographically very polarized country so
the two coasts are democratic and blue
the vast Center is dominated by
Republicans but given our system one has
to be able to go to protect women
minorities LGBTQ people in Mississippi
in Alabama in in Missouri where you know
it's a crime to drive while black in
many city but some people say the reason
that those states in the deep south is
so Republican is the fact that a
previous generation of Democrats and
some Republicans to be fair passed Civil
Rights Acts that changed the nature of
the voting in those particular states
not people who didn't like the changes
who were Democrats became Republicans
it's true and that's the hit we had to
take in Lyndon Johnson knew that but
that isn't that with every identity
politics to that you have to take some
of those hits as well for what you might
think is right if you can win but we are
not winning in a Center in the center of
the country and we cannot protect our
own people that's the problem
we're talking here about ways in which
authority and leadership come together
particularly United States but also in
Western Europe but it's worth
remembering that from first principles
there have always been proposals of
societies that didn't have leaders
anarchy in the truest sense of the word
not in the sense of being chaos or
necessarily kind of turbulent conflict
but operating without those kind of
top-down structures I mean Deirdre
McCloskey you would be I think frank and
saying that you're a libertarian you're
sorry once actually I want to take back
the word liberal okay I think is the
correct word and I'm willing to give to
to give to my friends on the Left Noam
Chomsky and so on the word progressive
I'm a liberal okay so you're a liberal
but you're a liberal who wants as little
government as possible could you
therefore take that thought to its
ultimate conclusion could we have a
society really without leadership and
would that function no I don't think so
in here I certainly agree with mark a
small government with with authority and
it's where you couldn't put bad people
in jail but only the bad people not the
good people where where the where the
government can can defend you in the
channel against the French who are
always thinking of invading Britain and
and and and our problem is Canada which
is extremely dangerous countries so so a
small government that does those jobs
effectively I'm all for but but I I want
to go back to something I said earlier
and ask Noam Chomsky if he doesn't agree
with language is a self-organizing
evolution languages your own great
scientific work on language is is very
much to the point here and I'd and so
much of what we do and our is not about
people ordering us around now I agree
you have to learn i completely agree
with your your speech about
so then this can this can apply to
children but once you're free adults
there there should be there there should
be an encouragement to spontaneous
orders such as language and large parts
of the economy I think you greatly good
we put those two points together and put
them to Nam Chomsky yeah should we be
looking to a society in which leadership
Authority and that top-down las' should
give way to something that's smaller
more spontaneous and bottom-up and if so
what in practice would that look like
I would agree with that I think we're
making a mistake solely on the political
son yeah the major structure to the
party and our society the main
construction party in our society are in
the economy well the economy is
basically running its run but
concentrated private power which people
can essentially at the very bottom of
the Wrentham so and then lastly room
meant furthermore that concentrated
private power has an overwhelming effect
political system matter that I briefly
indicated self warden in our society
would begin with economic inclusion it
would go back to what John Stuart Mill
and America and other workers talked
about them if you're in Lincoln book
about the way countries
nineteenth-century self-organized
that's who she's in which capital
doesn't hire labor but they'd hire that
that would be the basic unit
institutions well controlled by their
own participants that could be I
continue forward facing a system in
which power is generally dissolved both
of the political and economic system
carefully and placed increasingly in the
hands of popular self government
organizations which do accept delegation
of authority but only in a present way
of constant supervision by liberties
poverty groups and role and so on and I
think that's a direction so I kind of
knew we have to face the reality of this
happening so the pig would mark the
correctly said about the power respect
we should remember however one voting
participation is so important so they're
going making political scientist for the
environment and comments tourism looking
at the 2014 election but that's
legislative state turns out the voting
participation what about the level of
what it wasn't deployments more
properties inscriptions about the reason
like whether that is a collection of the
same kind of conditions that are leading
with authoritarian be generally anger
and temper institutions because of the
failure of this has been exaggerated
during the West Federation
charity programs bear in mind that wages
for permanent workers workers today are
actually at the level of 1960 it's just
not true increasing productivity that's
absolutely not true
ordinarily that's okay professor jobs he
thinks that apart from some little
disagreement I did hear at the end there
in some senses what did Roma closed ski
and Noam Chomsky have said has some
areas of convergence in terms of wanting
something that looks less like than like
top-down leadership and more like
spontaneous grassroots operation they
also both engage with the term liberal
which of course is something that you
know very well from your own work do you
see a liberal society also meaningfully
being one where leadership is less
top-down and less organized uh no not
not in the modern world we live in with
the modern economy but these ideas go
hand in hand the idea that authority is
this is the castle and the fantasy of
living without the castle even Deidre I
have to say when you speak the word
government it sounds like you're talking
about some alien spaceship that comes
down right and then sucks all the energy
out of the people then flies back up and
that's and that's not how things work
the whole point in our system is not to
fight Authority is to become the
authority and that means participation I
couldn't agree with Noam Chomsky more
about the crisis of participation and
that's why I'm the other side I actually
think that voting should be required an
Australian yeah I think that will be
good healthy report so what I'm into the
kind of liberalism that I'm for is a
kind of a kind of you know what's
sometimes called Civic republicanism
where there's a sense of public duty
public participation and yeah sense of
solidarity among citizens as as citizens
and but that means engaging and trying
to become the authority not have a fan
Seve escaping it's out of a free that
that vision you have would come out of a
freer society in which there's we're in
which we aren't slaves that's the key
it's it's actual slavery not the not the
wage slavery that that the nomes talking
about actual slavery ok so we have that
different views I think from our panel
this debate could go on and on it
deserves to but we are coming towards
time because we do you thank professor
Noam Chomsky professor Mark Miller
[Music]
professor did Deirdre McCloskey and our
newly our newly declared superhero
future liberal professor Mark Miller
thank you all very much
Mada Bates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you